herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute vielen dank an luca der neben ihr
sitzt plötzlich sein video clown dürfte
hallo mich auch gewundert hat warum die
letzten tage kam ich bin am streichen in
meiner neuen wohnung und ihr heute nicht
mal wieder im video auch weil du mir
sagen idee gegeben hat ja wer bis beide
euro geladen und ihre genaue dauer von
charles baidu gibt es auch genau
genommen habe mir das sogar in wales
schon mal gemacht der banken oder
untertitel formen
ich hab noch eingepackt und geht ich vor
mir heute anhand von tweets zu erraten
welcher youtuber sie geschrieben hat und
luca hat welche rausgesucht grafe erster
tweet drei neue videos werden in den
nächsten eineinhalb wochen
konzeptioniert gedreht und geschnitten
und ich bin jetzt schon mühe
er kannte drauf kommen ja also klingt
nach so viel aufwand den wir mal für
sein video zu treffen ich hab da so
einen gewissen
also ich tippe einfach mal auf julian
gedacht aber ich hatte in meinem bericht
ist das der zweite suite ich habe echt
einige bescheuerte wörter unbeabsichtigt
in meinem sprachgebrauch bieten lassen
aber für dinge würde ich mich schlagen
und also dass es anscheinend jemand sehr
konkret und mir pablo und sonst wie es
bei dir nur in bega frieden die
verteidiger aber ich mein wert nicht
kontra
der erreger konnte irgendjemand der
kombi kommt spontan dieser der haider
witwe dieser fünften kind erhält immer
so gehört beziehungsweise äußert sich
also gibt kritik zu diesen ganzen
youtube war der tausch werden kann ich
also schwer wenn er voll sind ja ich
habe echt einige bescheuerte wörter
unbeabsichtigt in meinen sprachgebrauch
fließen lassen aber für dinge würde ich
mich
schlagen ich könnte jetzt einen tipp
geben damit so ein bisschen katja jesus
kennt
wenn du kannst du machen wenn schwer war
durch meine frage stellen oder
vielleicht zwei tagen eine frage einzeln
hat diese person unter 500.000
abonnenten mehr als ein großes youtuber
ich denke dass man irgendwie so vom
gefühl her ich sag nicht mit mir selbst
ich glaube insgesamt 9300 gefällt mir
direkt im kriegsdienst zu kein mensch
für mich zu meiner zeit hat man
streiterei noch per breakdance battle
unten am fluss geklärt ergab ein tweet
nur windmill und baby frei
den hab ich gelesen und ich war ehrlich
ich weiß nicht ich habe den krieg
gelesen oder irgendwie gut merkt man
schon daran wie ihr verfassten inhalt
der täter wird beschrieben hat ja keine
gedanken über die fortsetzung also
werden diese break up denkt man ja
eigentlich antut ist aber nicht von
bluetooth ganz sicher weil ich hab mir
gedacht
der kommt der herr babbel und baby prix
verpackte welche wörter in sweden
das passt er verfolgt wie wir oft und ja
ich dachte krieg die wii remote baby
frei im gästebett
breakdance battle to break dance move
wird verdeutlichen welche wörter auf
englisch
wenn man wirklich unter kontrolle hat
luisi gehen
ich bin ruhig wie gehe ich vor zwei
wochen im nächsten die klappe klar ich
habe verriet dabei von 511
gleichbleibender facebook-nachricht ewig
schule
nein nicht mehr wird von jörg schmidt
wyk nicht man muss doch rein gehen
ich dachte auch darauf wie ihr geht
schon okay dass mehrere kabel nicht
immer blockade will für den vielleicht
mal vielen dank ich mal ohne den dingen
das ist ein sehr sehr langer und
strukturierter trieb ja ja auch
irgendwie niemand einen kanal mit
anderen zusammen hat der wert der wert
noch einen großen kanal wird ein bedarf
keine frage stellen was machen die
personen gaming videos mein gott ich
denke dass ich kaum einer ein kanu
zusammenhang
glück direkt drauf gekommen aber das
sehr gut dass natürlich auch bei den
tweet wir auch mehr an dem ich papa du
passend gemacht irgendwann kein gaming
haben sagen wir natürlich wieder das
wort und meisten leuten halt auch dieses
tier nicht gesehen
ich weiß nicht von heute samstag
abstreifen gutachten noch einen für mich
leute ich bin einfach echt geschlecht
verleiten
das war erster fürchtet wie du hast
jetzt von 582 richtig aber wir machen es
weiter mit dem wechsel war ein hoch auf
meine überteuerten winterreifen hat mich
doch noch belohnt hab ich gesehen da
gehen danke an heirat und man habe
erfährt eine nach hause kommt wir sind
beide 2017 nicht bei dem video data mit
start ab in dem film auch viele einsätze
wird in ganz deutschland und darf mich
im krieg war okay weg tritt und 16
wir machen musik das auffüllen könnt der
aber ich glaube nicht die war auch
letztes jahr nicht ein video der warum
sollten die sich rechtfertigen dafür da
für 2017 ich komm ich dachte ich muss
nichts aber ich weiß nicht was haben
werfen nachricht irgendwie schicken
wollte
was würden wir die botschaft übermittelt
wenn er ich wollte nie
die nehmen sich jetzt so ernst muss ich
das könnte auch wenn er dem fest nicht
eingetreten fertig ist der richtige mix
von dir wenn ich jetzt ein kleingewässer
wer klagt ein flop
und wie man überhaupt neben dem tief bei
den violetten startet verstehen mich
doch immer so aufregen auf die bühne und
platin romy schneider nach einem video
war ich in mainz kommen wir selber schon
monat als ihr nie dachte ich erinnere
ich sagen wir irgendwas hatte ich ja den
ganzen park machten durch weil über fast
eingeschlafen beim schneiden 30 19 12
durch
[Musik]
der geburtstag von meiner kleinen real
für die ganzheitlich frankfurt gelaufen
und ich habe die ganze zeit über die
sachen macht gefehlt und so weiter fort
ok hat für die nächsten könig machen
hier gmbh ja eigentlich muss ich mal ein
video machen wo ich eine richtig leckere
currywurst mache eine was hast du für
tui
das ist wie wenn du dich wenn du also
mitte verfolgt welche die rechte für
kommen garantierten koch channels ich
glaube kaum dass dem coach ein erfolg
dort weit fragen offen manchmal ob ich
wieder bin ich nach kochstelle fragen
bei einem cocktail verhöre erstens ein
mann ist ein gamer ja geht wieder
irgendwelchen sturm wo wir eine welt für
sich zu sehen hier in dem bildschirm
wird nach 15 minuten noch ein markt
currywurst mal wenn du das gefühl hast
auf twitter was ich jetzt gerade
gleichstand glaub ich oder du hast drei
bis vier täter oder niemals was will man
mehr mit den letzten tweet ihr wolltet
mich schon immer mal ein bisschen
höheren wahrscheinlich mit hier das
video dazu
auch diana können
unterwegs ja ich hab ich hab auch mal
wie es erstes mal challenging
aufgenommen darf ich dann auch wirklich
schrecklich und ich hätte mir vorstellen
hätten sich auch darauf getötet habe
aber okay ich glaube du hast insgesamt
gewonnen
natürlich kann es entweder 34 medien
babys hat am ende noch wie man richtig
ja stimmt okay ich hatte viel richtig
gemacht hatte julian beim richtig wetter
richtig dann richtig richtig und im
moment leute gleich noch mal mit einer
anderen deutschen medien plattform weit
wir wollen sie auch schon mit instagram
machen wollt ihr sehen dann schafft mal
10.000 dollar vielleicht kommt echt hart
mit uns machen wir beide nie wieder
video nie wieder ruini rädern leute
fabuliert umfasst auch okay